c'est pas en jeu vous attirer
l'attention sur vous donc sur nous ce
qui pourrait nous faire tous fusillés
quelle est votre mission l'opération
anthropoïde on est ici pour assassiner
reinhard heydrich
il a exécuté des milliers d'âmes il n'ya
que hitler et himmler au dessus de lui
dans la hiérarchie nazie
vous êtes complètement malade si vous
tuez heydrich la colère d'hitler
s'abattra sur prague
est ce que notre pays est toujours prêt
et a toujours eu envie de résister à
l'envahisseur allemand
messieurs cette opération va mobiliser
quasiment tous les derniers effectifs de
la résistance son escorte armée 30
secondes derrière si on vous arrête
il n'y aura pas d'échappatoire que dieu
soit avec vous peut-être que c'était une
erreur de ne pas vous informer du danger
elle est très jeune elle a encore une
vision romantique de la guerre la guerre
n'a rien de romantique il y a un
problème
servez vous il est de votre devoir de
rester en vie et de continuer à vous
battre